so a new book is coming out by Johnny
Carson's former lawyer a guy named Henry
Bushkin who was Carson's lawyer from
1970 to 1988 which were many of Johnny's
prime years right in there and and he's
just bashing Johnny and of course Johnny
long gone at this point he's saying he
was difficult to work with the bad
husband a bad father he always carried a
gun he was unhappy blah blah blah now
first of all what happened to
attorney-client privileges and there's
some sort of well I don't know some of
the things that you listed there are not
particularly attorney-client privilege
just things that he observed from
spending I think 18 years with Johnny
but but he goes into pretty it's very
it's so exploitive it's so exploitative
I think that's really unethical yeah I
think it's really unethical so I wanted
what I wanted to talk to you guys about
this was just the comedian aspect of
this because comedians were known to be
that this comes from a dark place and
we're all warped and messed up and all
this stuff don't we have a right to that
sort of if we're gonna if we're gonna
make people laugh and talk about the
truth and all that stuff don't we have a
right to it and then that it shouldn't
be splashed once where once we're gone
oh no I just I mean I first of all I
have nothing to hide anybody wants to
write a book about me like after I'm
dead I'm fine I love your life I really
don't care yeah but that's one thing
when you talk about you know us being
you know dark and and that type of
personality but when he know you think
there's sort of this implication that he
was this friendly guy that everyone know
what they're what he's really what
they're trying to do in the book is be
like it wasn't there was a terrific
documentary about Johnny Carson earlier
and and I and I worked on the show and I
met him and I conversed with him to a
point and he was not a very social
person and it's not it's not a secret
you know he was an uncomfortable person
and and it said that in the documentary
but I think and not having read this
book I think that Bushkin goes beyond
and you know when he talks about trying
to break into his wife's ex-wife's
apartment I mean that's illegal I mean
that's illegal stuff that you that's
it's completely exploitative right and
also always carrying around a gun and
all that so I mean is this just another
example of just somebody just trying to
make a buck somebody you know and I will
have to admit that I am glad that his
lawyer has such low standards and no
ethics because it's fun to read this guy
it really really happy to hear fact that
Johnny Carson was even more flawed than
I am and you know the fact that he would
be I know that he married three women
named Joanna right right and but the
thing is when he went to his wife had
taken out any apartment she was leasing
an apartment where she would go and have
sexual trysts with her lover and it
turned out her lover was Frank Gifford
oh boy the MVP the MVP or I know what
bragging the MVP but wonder johnny was
pissed yeah so and then but it was there
is some funny insights the way he dealt
with so one night he's drinking at a bar
and he calls up at McMahon was ray after
he found on his wife was Jesus read this
book so I read parts of it there was
exhibition and so he's sitting there
drinking drinking with Ed and then when
the lawyer shows up he said he turns the
end goes we're done here right ed and
then it just gets up and walks away it
was kind of like oh yeah yeah so you
know what I mean that's it so okay so
this will all this stuff is again from
1970 to 1988 before Twitter and Facebook
and all that stuff and Johnny clearly
had no privacy even then so should any
of us expect anyone that's even remotely
in the public eye at all should we
expect to have any privacy wet while
we're alive or when we're alone it's
really up to the ethics of individuals
and there are a lot of people who who
don't respect other people's privacy and
that's the way it's gonna be and that's
why I like to have no secrets because
then nobody can hurt me that's an
accident so I could tell people about my
propecia use so it can't be used against
me yeah I think they'll say about Jimmy
when he's long gone that wasn't his real
hair
thank you so but you're talking about
you know this revealing what a dark side
Johnny Carson had and you know somehow
comedians are I think everyone has dark
sides I think everyone is messed up
horribly and that's that comedians just
have a talent they've just you know
doing take it and yes Jerry Seinfeld
thought the way he said that he says you
know he was talking with Garry Shandling
and Garry Shannon was saying don't you
think we come from a place where we need
this attention we need it that's why we
get on stage that's why and in Jerry
Seinfeld says yeah or we can have talent
that could be that and I agree I think
that comedians are Jerry would never
admit that he has a dark side right
what's the deal with the dark side that
I don't know I think that we all I think
everyone has dark sides and I I think
that's why people connect with those
kind of stories and I just think again
that comedians have talent to be able to
like make light of them yeah don't you
think but is it hard for people people
with dark with the worst you know if
everything's hunky-dory in your life
what what are happy families are all
happy in the same way it's unhappy
families are all unhappy uniquely yeah I
don't know if I'm butchering that quote
but so that's why you need you don't
need comedy if everything's hunky-dory
in your life that's why I say you know
conservatives don't do comedy they're
the reason we need comedy in the first
[ __ ] place yeah so that that I think
that everybody's messed up and don't
tell you it is interesting out there or
not there are not really I did when
Dennis Miller one conservative he got
because why well you creepy [ __ ] he got
a lot of money out of Bill O'Reilly you
kept a comedy is supposed to punch
upward right exactly posted that and
when it goes downward its called
bullying right so Dennis Miller is a
bully right he's not actually comedian
he's not using comedy in the service of
the underdog he's using comedy in the
service of the bully and that's why he's
not a comedian he says that care is as
Andy Kindler says Dennis Miller a
retired comedian yeah even he would be
able to see right so by the way I
apologize for implying that Jerry
Seinfeld may have had it they have a
dark side you acknowledge that Jimmy and
you
me man oh god I mean I have a very I
such a dark side yeah I was at my
friend's house the other day if he lives
on one of the canyons and I said you
know what's great about your house if
you want to commit suicide you just walk
out and try it across the street that's
how I look at things well there you go
yeah we usually don't end on suicide but
I feel like that was a pretty I always
end on Suez a pretty solid ending the
Reuben report brought to you by Cooper
comm they've got up to 75% off cat and
dog treats toys and more you can get
another 20% off using code RR the link
is right down below click it and make
your pet happy